(crowd cheering)
- [Audience Member] I love you.
- Ah, I love you back.
Bro.
Thank you so much for such
an unbelievable welcome.
Actually, we've been
talking backstage,
and I guess
I'm gonna actually see
how you guys react to this.
As I've been kind of
prepping for this talk,
following the hashtag,
following the momentum
the last couple of weeks and
now with such a warm welcome.
I feel like I'd be
doing a disservice
if I kind of spent, you
know, the 73% of this talk
on stuff that you've
seen on YouTube
or have seen me before do.
I'm of the mindset
of possibly going into
a complete hour of Q&amp;A.
(crowd cheering)
But I can also give a talk.
Look, why don't
we do it this way,
how many people would
like to start lining up
and go into Q&amp;A and
see where that takes us
and then I'll do a
talk on the back end
if that's not the
right direction.
Show of hands.
(crowd cheering)
And how many
people want the talk?
(crowd cheering)
Fuck, it feels very 50/50.
(crowd laughing)
That totally fucking backfired.
Shit.
Alright, why don't we do
this, why don't we do this.
Why don't I start
riffing a little bit.
Why don't the people who
want to ask questions
actually line up and
start getting behind
the mics and maybe
I'll create some fucking
weird Toronto hybrid of
fucking talk and Q&amp;A.
And take it from there.
Let me start talking
about some of the stuff
that's interesting
to me right now.
I think that one thing
that everybody in this room
should be pondering and
one thing that I'm becoming
extremely fascinated
by is that we,
I'm fascinated by
the fact that really,
I'll be able to do this
for the rest of my life
and I'll be able to
continue to build businesses
that are successful and
yet, it's just basically
the same shit over and over.
Which is, which is,
if you go and dissect
what I'm about to talk
about for an hour now
and go watch a
2009 talk, it's basically
the same exact strategy.
The only differences is,
is that I've put in the time
and the effort to understand
the contextual differences
of the places that we're
actually paying attention to.
If this talk was about
how I built Wine Library
in the beginning back in
2001, I would still be talking
about the one thing that
I think connects all of us,
which is, I don't care
what you do here
or what your ambition is,
to solve the world's problems,
to start a business,
to whatever it may be.
A B to B business,
a B to C business, a product,
a service, the number one
thing we all battle for
and the number one
North Star that everybody
in this room should understand
is, it's all about attention.
Attention is the asset.
Once you have the attention,
then what you say,
what you do, what you
put out, the creative,
is the variable of you
being massively successful
or nobody giving a fuck, right?
And so, the thing
that I've been doing is
very simply not being romantic
about where the attention is.
I would've loved for it to
have stayed on Twitter forever.
I moved first, I moved the best,
I was one
of the 20 most
followed people on it
and had the world frozen
in 2011 and stayed still
and that played out, I would
have been in a very nice spot.
I didn't want to put in
the hours from one
to four in the morning
figuring out SocialCam
and Vine, which then
gave me the strategies
and the abilities to
be good at Snapchat
and Instagram Video,
but, I always know
that it is completely
irrelevant, everything I've done
up to this moment.
If I want to be successful
and if I want to be
in a place where
I'm blessed with the fact
that people want to
come and see me talk.
Really, it's quite scary to me,
I'm thrilled to
layer on top of it,
but the punchline, and literally
I could say this and leave,
because it's the
only thing I believe in,
which is, you need to understand
where the attention is.
The better your
product or service is,
the more successful
you're gonna be
'cause I promise you one thing,
there's no marketing
strategy or tactic
that I'm gonna be able to
tell you that if your product
is shit, it's not going to work.
(crowd laughing)
Right?
So, it's better if
your thing is good,
your wine store,
your book, your sneaker,
your SaaS product.
It's better if your
thing is good, however,
the punchline of
everything I believe in
and the things that have
given me opportunities
to be successful is, where
is the attention right now
that is under priced, and that's
a very important variable.
TV and outdoor and
billboards and Google AdWords
and all this stuff,
they still work,
they just don't work
as well for the time
and financial allocation
as the moment
when they were in their prime.
Facebook works
ridiculously well right now
if you're an actual
practitioner of it.
And in 36 months,
it won't work as well,
because it will be more
expensive to achieve
the same exact
result as you do today.
I'm not spending time
on Musical.ly right now
for any other reason
than if it actually pops
and goes mainstream in the ages
above eight to 12 year olds
and becomes a platform.
Because don't forget,
just five minutes ago,
Facebook was
only for college kids.
If it does that, I want
to have the land grab,
the 100,000 followers
I already have on a platform
that's only eight
to 12-year-old girls.
Will turn into nothing for me,
other than maybe
go to fucking jail.
(crowd laughing)
Is gonna turn
into nothing for me
unless it ages up.
But when it does,
I'm there and I win.
My game is quite simple.
I want to buy up
beach front property
and build the best buildings
and restaurants and homes.
And as long as I'm right
one of three times,
the ROI was positive
for all the work.
It blows my mind how many of
you in marketing and business
drew a line in the sand
and did not want to start
a Snapchat account
earlier this year
because you were scared the
amount of time and effort
that you would put into it
wouldn't have a result for you
when you have to realize
that's the only thing
you should be doing.
Rinse and repeat, rinse and
repeat, on every platform
until you have your
moment of your arbitrage.
I've had four to five
significant moments
of this day trading attention.
It started in 1996 by actually
even having a website.
As I look around here,
there's a lot of youngsters
in the crowd,
but for a couple of us
who were around back
then, in 1994, five, six,
people debated if
the internet was a fad
the way we debate
a new app being a fad.
The whole fucking thing.
My dad got made
fun of by all his friends
that we didn't open
a second liquor store,
instead we built a website.
Right?
That was the first being right
about under priced attention.
'Cause $15,000 to build a
website is a hell of a lot
less than a million dollars
to build a liquor store
and that website generated
40 million dollars in sales
and no way would've that
liquor store done that.
That was the right rub.
I did that in tactics by
other moves, including email.
How many people in this audience
have done email marketing
in their career,
raise your hands.
Wow, awesome!
That was awesome!
This is going to be
even more awesome.
In 1997, I had 200,000
people on an email newsletter
that had 91.3% open rates.
(crowd clapping)
Don't clap for me.
I'm no hero,
it was just a timing thing.
It was because all of you
assholes hadn't started
email marketing yet.
(crowd laughing)
Right?
Now that same email's bigger,
it's been around for a
decade, or two decades,
and yet, it's got
31.7% open rates, right?
The open rates is one thing.
I think it had at one
point, like 59% click
in the email to add to cart.
It was unbelievable.
We built a business on it.
Then Google AdWords
came along, right?
I literally, thank God I
wasn't making videos back then,
I was like, this Google
thing is stupid,
why don't they have
ads on the homepage.
But, when Google AdWords
started, I bought the word wine
for five cents a click,
because back then the minimum
was five cents,
not ten cents a click.
And I owned it for nine
and a half months
before anybody bid me up.
That was the arbitrage.
Now that same term wine
is a $4.37 word, right.
It's no different.
But there's millions of
stories of me doing that,
where it didn't work
out, hence, SocialCam,
or if you're hardcore web 2.0.
How many of you remember
Plurk, the thing that was
the next Twitter,
but it went this way
instead of this way,
it was fucking crazy.
Anyway.
(audience laughing)
And so, basically, my
core moves were a website,
an email newsletter,
a Google Ad campaign,
and then for a lot of
you, you may know this,
my career took it's biggest
turn when three months
after it came out, there was
something called YouTube.
I looked at it, I'm like,
I think this is gonna be big.
And within the year of
YouTube being in existence,
before any one video had
ever hit one million views,
I started a 20-minute wine
show, called Wine Library TV
and it worked.
It was the first time that
content was driving sales for
me.
Weirdly enough, on a show where
I was panning my own wines.
And it really changed the
course of my career in many ways
because it drug me more
into the web 2.0. world,
YouTube sold for two billion
dollars, I got freaked out
by that, I said this
talent can do more for me,
so I decided to
invest in the next things
that I believed in.
In order those
three things were Twitter,
Facebook, and Tumblr.
That was good and that's
how we got here, right?
It was very good.
And so, and so, I might be
able to buy the Jets, good.
(crowd laughing)
(crowd clapping)
I guess what I'm
trying to figure out and
what's the biggest legacy
I can leave from tonight's talk
is a couple of pillars of,
there are tried-and-true things
that will happen, for example,
what am I most fearful of?
I'm fearful that this room has
a lot of fake entrepreneurs
that are running companies that,
when the global
economy slows down
and they can't raise money,
that they'll go out of business
because they're not actually
building a business,
they're building a
product and really just
a financial arbitrage machine.
And all their behavior is
predicated on appeasing VCs
who won't be there for you
when you get to the next step.
Right? Thanks for the clap, bro.
(audience applause and laughter)
So that I'm worried about.
And I'm worried about a
lot of different things,
the supply and demand of
everybody doing the same thing.
Right, there's a million of
things I'm worried about,
or what are dangerous things
for all of us in this room.
What am I most in control of?
I'm most in control
of talking to you guys
about self-awareness and what
actually allows you to win.
I know that one of the
only things I do well
because it's just true,
one of the only things
I do better than the market is,
I am intuitive of what
people are gonna do,
slightly ahead and fast enough.
And it's really
always backed by data.
I love when people are like,
"You were so early on Snapchat."
Yeah, after it spent a year
on the top of
the app store, right?
It's just that I'm
willing to put in the work
that so few others
are because I view it
as the cost of entry,
not a risk move.
And I'm stunned by
how many people
could go to a
conference like this,
know who I am and
the other speakers are,
and continue to poo-poo
innovation changes
'cause it's not convenient
to your work ethic
or how you're making money
when you have the audacity
to wanna live the life
that you actually
wanna live in this room.
And, to me,
that's the punchline.
Like, in a world where,
(audience applause)
In a world where
there's no fuckin' way
you're here tonight,
in this room,
and you don't have
massive ambition
and you are seeing the world
in a different way
than the masses.
Don't go get
caught up in our bubble.
You are seeing the
world in a different way
than 99% of people,
I just don't understand
when you're asking for the
fruits at this high of a level,
why so many of you are
not putting in the work.
I have startups that I'm
an investor in right now
that have three months'
worth of money left,
have no money coming
their way whatsoever,
the product is shit,
(audience laughter)
they're out of business
in three months,
and they went to
fuckin' Coachella.
(audience laughter)
And so that to me is what's
a very fascinating thing
that I wanna, like,
figure out through Q&amp;A
or this talk or fuckin'
email me, I don't know but
we are living through a
remarkable time
where business people are people
that people wanna
take selfies with.
The entrepreneur has never
been more put on a pedestal
and this shit is
gonna crash down.
It's just what always
happens and to me,
I feel a massive sense of
responsibility as a human being,
as somebody who's
benefited from it,
to really talk about it.
Because there's a lot of
shit we're not talking about
in our world.
I have acquaintances, thank you.
(audience applause)
I mean, not to go Debbie Downer
and I'll get out
of this very quickly,
but I wanna get
this off my chest,
I have acquaintances that
are in deep depression
and if you're paying attention
to the tech business world,
there's people that are
committing suicide
because their businesses
are not successful
and yet, our entire world
is saying anybody can do it,
it's so easy, celebrating
when people raise money.
Congrats, you gave away
a piece of your business
because you weren't good
enough to make money.
Fuck face.
(audience applause and laughter)
Congrats, like.
We have totally, totally
allowed the VC community
to paint a certain narrative and
because it is now easier to go
and start a company
and raise money
instead of going
and getting a job,
and by the way, I don't
blame one youngster.
Should I, A, go and work
at a job at entry level
in the current
ecosystem of the world
and be treated like shit
and not make a lot of money?
Or should I,
B, go raise a bunch of money
and do my own thing and be
my own boss and seem cool,
and if it fails, there's
really fundamentally
no repercussion and I learned?
And so we're in this
very interesting time.
And so what I wanna
do in this room today
is start having a far more
interesting debate of,
do you wanna win?
Because let me
promise you something,
being number 18 at Instagram
made you a lot more money
than being number
one at Instashit.
(audience laughter)
And I think there's a lot
of people in this room
who are not putting themselves
in a position to succeed
because they either
lack self-awareness,
or B, are just blindly
following the narrative
of the current ecosystem.
And I wanna suffocate
the conversation
to see if we can provide
more value to our ecosystem
because there are so many things
that we are not talking about.
I am thrilled through Q&amp;A to
give you the detailed ways
to make Instagram stories
provide you more upside
if you sell homemade
jam, thrilled to do it.
You like that?
That was a good one, right?
(audience laughter)
Homemade jam's funny.
But I equally wanna challenge
this hour we have together
to, like, level up
the conversation
because for, again, and I'm
watching some of the people
that have been around the block
a couple times like I have.
This is a foregone conclusion,
this is 93% of the
people in this room
are working at TD Bank
and Rogers in 18 months.
And so, there's a
way to not do that.
That way is called, to
become quite practical.
That way is called, actually
build a fucking business.
That way is called,
know what you're good at
and surround yourself
with the other things
so that you can do the other
two things I just mentioned.
The problem is, that shit is
not as sexy to talk about.
I'm here to fuckin'
talk about it.
(audience applause)
That felt good.
Let's mix it up.
- [Ashley] Alright,
I saw you, is this on?
- What's your name?
Yes, you're on.
- It's Ashley.
- [Gary] Hey, Ashley.
- Saw you last
week in Lake Placid.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- And apologize for
almost railroading you
in the trade show.
- Louder, louder?
- [Ashley] Sorry.
- No worries, can you guys
make this louder too, or no?
No? Go ahead.
- Almost slammed into
you at the trade show,
so sorry about that,
- No worries.
It was funny because you
were so busy on Snapchat
you didn't fuckin' notice.
- [Gary] Yeah, I get it.
- It's just great.
(audience laughter)
- [Gary] It's so weird.
- My question to you is,
I do television,
multi-club owner,
all that kind of stuff,
(mumbles)
I'm starting a YouTube channel
I actually give a shit about
versus just putting content out.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I'm pretty sure a lot
of people in this room
are doing the same thing as me,
so read all your books,
have 'em, whatever,
what is the best
piece of advice for me,
who's actually starting to
give a shit about YouTube?
- So when you say give a
shit, let's define that first.
- So I'm putting the time
in, relevant content,
- And what would you
like the content to do?
Have people sign
up for your gym?
Which is great,
you're running a business.
- Buy my book.
- Buy your book, okay, here's
the advice I would give you.
So is the book alive and real?
- [Ashley] Yeah, it's on Amazon.
- Got it.
I would take,
the first strategy would be
to do everything you can to
not get people to buy the book.
The second you
make the shift and think
that you're not
selling the book,
but that you're
building a media company
that provides people value
around what you wrote about,
you will have a
fundamental difference.
It is stunning to me
how many more books
I sell than most people by
spending as much
time as possible
giving away the
book for free, like,
there's no reason to
buy any of my books,
as a lot of you know,
if you've decided
to watch everything I've
said for a year for free.
So it's a timesaver, if you
decide to go that route,
but it is stunning Ashley.
Can I call you Ash?
- [Ashley] Yes, you may.
- Great, Ash,
(audience laughter)
it is stunning how
many people here
bought my book
out of sheer guilt
and wanting to give back
to what I gave them.
How many people here buy
my shit because of that?
(audience applause)
And so, I think
if you're thinking
you're doing a YouTube
channel and producing content
because you wanna sell the book,
you're gonna be selling
and that's the quickest way
to not sell something.
And so I would just provide
unbelievable content,
force them to
not need that book,
and that's how I would
go about the content.
Amount of people
here that hold back
the thing that
they're trying to sell,
that didn't realize that if they
gave away that hold back thing,
they would sell a lot more.
The other thing I would do,
is I would do a
lot of Facebook video
and run target ads against it.
YouTube's a great channel,
it's unbelievable,
it's highly competitive and
very difficult for discovery
and takes a lot
of time to build momentum,
unless you're doing JVs
with other YouTube stars.
Whereas in a
Facebook environment
you can get very
narrowed by spending
50 and a $100 in ads
to amplify the
video that you made,
so I would not, in 2017,
have a YouTube-only strategy
with not complimenting
it with Facebook.
Awesome, nice meeting you.
- Thank you.
Yeah, for sure.
(audience applause)
- [Resh] It's on?
- Yeah.
- Yup.
- My name is Resh. I sell
tele and web conferencing.
I know that my products are
the best in the country.
- [Gary] Because your mom
said or you believe it?
- Haha (audience laughter).
No, no.
Because of the data.
- [Gary] Okay.
- The statistics
- [Gary] Yup. Okay.
- Here's a problem.
When I go out and tell people
that we have the best service,
I know 100% that I do
that. I was a former chef,
and I know that 100% that
service, without service,
your products can be great,
but without good service
you will fail.
- [Gary] Okay.
- How do I convey that to
my clients or prospects
when they don't believe
me, when they're just happy
with what they have,
and they're willing to pay
like a little bit more?
- By not spending any time
trying to convince them.
So, let's break
this down. And again,
if I'm going to do Q&amp;A,
I'm going to mix here
between giving
advice to all of you
and then bouncing
back to giving advice.
So, the reason I answered that
is at a across this
whole room standpoint,
the amount of time many of you
are spending trying
to convince somebody
who's not sellable
to buy your thing
is destroying
your top-line growth.
I've always sold shit
that nobody believed in.
Whether it was
new regions of wine,
whether it was social media,
whether it was me,
I've always sold things
that nobody believed in,
and by spending zero time,
spending one second to audit
if they believed in it
and once recognizing
that they didn't,
moving on, it has allowed me
to be far more successful.
Now, specifically for you,
there's a second-layer question.
If there's only 80 people in
the world that could buy it,
you don't have that
many more to go to.
So depending on how many
people you can sell to,
if you can sell to everybody,
or to a lot of people,
you should spend zero seconds
trying to convince
somebody who's unsellable
and keep trying to find the
next person that is sellable,
that's why both the
businesses that I've run
have grown in top-line
revenue very quickly.
It's a very, very rare thing
for some reason,
but it brings enormous value.
If you have 80 people,
or 150 people,
then you have to go in
reverse and go deep as fuck,
be patient as hell, and
chip away on a human level,
'cause people buy from people.
But convincing anybody on
something that is subjective,
'cause it's subjective, bro,
like you being the best
at service is subjective.
No shit you think you are.
But I don't know if
that's worth more to me
than what I've got in place,
and you know this,
nobody likes change.
If they have legacy
infrastructure,
the pain of change is always
scaring entrepreneurs.
People are scared of change.
That's where all the money is.
And so, that would be my answer.
- [Resh] Okay.
- Yeah, (applause) Awesome.
- You say you don't want
the Jets to win, right?
- [Gary] What's that?
- You hope that the Jets don't
win the Super Bowl, right?
- Yeah, I mean for the
people that follow my stuff
I secretly probably weirdly
don't want them to win
because I want to
buy them and win it,
and it's just a better
story for the Disney film.
- [Resh] Fingers crossed
that they don't?
- [Gary] Yeah, fingers crossed
that they don't.
- [Resh] Thank you
for the gentle words outside.
- Of course.
- [Resh] And if you
care to for a drink
for five minutes later,--
- Are you hitting on me, bro?
(audience laughter)
- [Resh] My girlfriend
wouldn't appreciate that.
- (Laughs) Respect.
- Hey.
- Gary, Daniel.
- Hey, Daniel.
- So I train sales
people. I have about 300
from relationship, action,
goals, lazy,
80/20 rule and all that stuff.
- [Gary] Yup, yes.
- And I've got ideas
coming to me all the time.
"Daniel we should do this,"
"Daniel we should do that,"
- [Gary] Yup.
- "We're going to
increase by doing this."
- [Gary] Yup.
- "I went to this event,
we should apply this,"
So I guess my question is is
how do I build that core group
of people I actually listen
to, to apply those principles
to move our business forward?
Because I've got 300, you
know, questions coming my way
of how we should do things.
How would you
build your core group
and who would you listen to?
- I don't listen to anybody.
(audience laughter)
- All right.
- And I'm being dead serious.
But I equally
listen to everybody.
And so I know that's an
interesting contradiction,
but the truth is, you're asking
me how to make a decision,
in it's rawest form,
- Yeah, yeah.
- And the truth is your
success needs to be predicated
on how you make decisions.
Like, my whole life is
taking in data at scale,
and then how I synthesize,
how many people here
work in big data?
Raise your hands.
So, for the few of you,
like, I'm so fascinated
by big data, right?
It's such a buzzword.
Everybody's talk, but it's,
big data's not the punchline.
What you do with the
data is the punchline.
Right? So, like, how you
synthesize or interpret it
is the punchline of big data.
I don't know, bro.
- [Daniel] Do you
care that if that person
has a good track record
or a bad track record
in the business?
- I sure don't. Michael Jordan
sucked on the Wizards.
- [Daniel] Yeah. It's true.
(audience laughter)
- [Daniel] And do you
have a core-
- That was good.
I like that.
I've never used that one before.
- [Daniel] Gary-
- I fucking hate Michael Jordan,
too, so that's perfect.
- Do you have a
core group yourself?
- No, man. I would tell you-
- It's all your thing?
- I would tell you
that my biggest flaw,
and I don't think of
this as a cool thing,
I don't think my lack of mentors
or my leaning on others is cool.
I don't.
I just know it's me, and
I'm unable to break me.
I just don't want to listen
to anybody else. I just don't.
And I swear on my
life I do not think that
that makes me great or awesome.
I genuinely believe it's a flaw,
and I think that there's a
lot of things that I'll learn
at 45 and 52 and 57 that
I literally could learn
tomorrow over a drink,
it's just, I don't want to.
(audience laughter)
- [Daniel] Thanks, man.
Never change, bro. Thanks.
- Yeah. Thank you, bro.
- Hey, man.
- Hi. I'm fascinated by your
film, short documentary,
Document, Not Create.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I love
imitating you, like,
with facial
expressions and such.
- [Gary] (laughing) Okay.
- So, I'm going to
ask you a question.
I'm going to ask you
a question as GaryVee.
- Okay (laughs).
(audience laughter)
- Right everybody?
- [Gary] (laughs)
- You look at Beyonce today.
You look at Barak Obama today.
We don't look at how much work
they've put in their game.
You can tell me I work
smart, I don't work hard.
I can tell
you something, asshole.
I work smart and hard, too.
- [Gary] (laughs)
(audience applause and cheering)
- Thank you so much.
So, I started
this project called
"What would you do,
"what would you do if you're
not afraid?" And I said-
- [Gary] What would
you do if what?
- If you're not afraid.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- 30 days challenge
documenting myself
based on your, you know,
connecting, to what you're
created.
What would you do
if you're not afraid?
I'm asking you the question,
and then if you like it,
I would love to challenge
everybody here,
instead of just go
and become lazy,
to, for 30 days, document
what they're doing
and we create a documentary
in about all the good stories
that we've been creating. And
I love you so much, GaryVee.
- [Gary] I love you, bro, too.
(audience laughter)
- So what's the question?
(laughs)
(audience laughter)
- The question is, "What
would you do as GaryVee
"today,
"if you're not afraid?"
- You know, it's interesting.
I, I-
(audience laughter)
I'm going to tell you something.
This is a very, I can't
believe I'm going to go there.
So, I got really lucky.
I'm stunningly
unafraid in my lane.
Right?
Like, one of the things
that I implore so many
of you to really debate,
why I preach self-awareness,
and I don't speak
to how to find it
because I don't think I know,
I think you need to talk
about the shit you know.
Here's what I know.
It's fucking important.
Right?
How you get there, I don't know.
I think there's
a lot of hardwiring,
I think there's a lot of
parenting issues,
I think there's
a lot of other people
that can tackle that issue.
But the reason
I almost feel like I never,
I'm like living life
completely unafraid is,
it's I won't go out of
my comfort zone, my lane,
in business, in this.
Like if this was
40 million people,
I'm so cozy, because
I'm talking about my shit.
If they gave me a piece of
paper to read to you right now,
I would shit my fucking pants.
Because I can't read.
Like, I'm being dead
serious with you.
Like I'd be like, "The-"
You know, I mean it's
like not that bad,
but it's pretty fucking bad.
(audience laughter)
(audience cheer)
- When I think about like,
like I've genuinely thought
about this based
on this question.
I've been having this weird idea
for the last two or three years
to actually go
out in public naked.
(audience laughter)
- [Audience Member] Let's do it!
- I think it's
the scariest thing.
No, no, no. I'm not doing it.
But- (laughs)
(audience laughter)
Bro! Bro! That's the easy part.
(Audience Laughter)
So I don't know, look,
I don't know how to answer it,
but here's what I can tell you:
I think, I think that,
I think it's actually
more interesting
to have a conversation of
how do you put yourself
in a position that you're
actually never afraid.
That if you close your world
and you believe
in what you believe
and you stay to
the shit you know,
like what then starts to happen.
Because what starts to happen,
at least from somebody who's
been really executing this
for a little while now,
you start getting
confidence completely
because you're just there.
You know, and more importantly,
way too many of us-
something happened to me
three or four years ago.
I started getting very
quiet in environments
where I didn't know what the
fuck I was talking about.
So when I go out with friends,
I think we all-
there's something I still,
to this day,
and I'm almost done with it,
it's almost fully out of me.
You know how many times-
think about how many times
somebody's said to you, like,
"Hey, you know this, right?"
And you're like, "Uh, huh,"
and you have no fucking idea?
(audience laughter)
I do that all the time.
Ten years ago.
And I've been
chipping away at it,
and it's been liberating
and unbelievable.
And I would tell you that
when I go out with friends
or couples with my wife, and
we talk about healthcare,
politics, or science,
I get real quiet.
I, me, could go through a
whole dinner being like,
ridiculously quiet,
which is fucking insane.
And I would tell you, start
becoming more black and white
about get deeper and better
in the shit that you know
and what comes natural to
you, and get real quiet,
don't feel a need to have
your two fucking cents
on every fucking
thing in the world.
(audience applause)
- So are we starting the
documentary challenge to ask
for people to document
what they're working on
for 30 days?
And I will make an awesome
documentary out of it?
- I think you asked.
That's on them.
- [Audience Member] So
guys, I'm asking you
- (Laughs) No hesitation.
- for 30 days,
- To document what the frickin'
you're working on
and not be scared.
And we're going
to make an amazing,
kick-ass documentary about it.
For 30 days.
- But don't do it unless he
sits the rest of this talk
without his shirt on.
(audience laughter)
- So I should stay the rest
of the talk without shirt?
- Yes, in a seat, though.
You need to get out of the mic.
You've taken up too much time.
(audience cheering and laughter)
- Thank you everybody.
- You're welcome.
- Hey Gary.
My name is Richard.
- [Gary] Hey Richard.
- My daughter's 17.
She's going to a
meeting tonight with my wife--
- Yes.
- [Richard] to discuss with
her school her
university options,
what she wants to do.
She's incredibly
courageous marketing mind,
communications mind.
I'm taping you right now and
I'd like you to talk to her
like she was your
17 year old daughter
in terms of how she should
consider her university career,
how she should maximize
that experience to prepare her
for the world that you
see she may be entering into.
- Oooph.
(audience laughter)
- [Richard] Her name is Kiara.
- [Gary] Kiara, I have no idea
what's about to happen but
it's about to get
interesting, Kiara.
Here's what I would say Kiara.
I would tell you that there's
not a school on Earth,
not a university or
college that exists
that is even remotely equipped
to educate you properly
on communications and marketing
in the world we live in today.
So,
(audience applause)
I have no interest, Kiara,
to get your mom
and dad mad at me
but I would tell you that here
would be my four year strategy.
I would go to university,
especially, is she going
here in Canada?
- [Richard] She's
talking about NYU,
she's talking about San Fran.
- Is she collecting debt or
are you guys paying for it?
- [Richard] I think she's just
enamored by big brands.
- But is she gonna
pay for college?
- [Richard] Yeah,
we're paying for it.
- So she's not collecting debt.
- [Richard] I apologize.
We're paying for it
and yes, she's going to
collect debt along the way.
- Alright, Kiara, you're gonna
have to have a weird
conversation with
your mom and dad.
(audience laughter)
Because the first thing
I'm passionate about
is for you to not have any debt.
Because if you're
gonna go to a business
that is gonna sell
you a shit product
that you are then gonna pay
compounded interest in
that you can't even declare
bankruptcy to get out of
that's called extortion fucked
up fucking crazy ass shit.
(audience cheers and applause)
But, but Kiara, if that
number's not that high
and you can get some other
things that drives down that
cost the second move
would be to take
your last four year
vacation of your life.
Hook up a whole bunch.
(audience laughter)
Or not depending on
your own radar, Kiara,
that might be one dude,
seven, that's on you.
Don't let them judge.
- [Richard] She's a nice
good Christian girl.
- I'm sure she is.
(Richard laughs)
(audience laughter)
And if you want to learn about
marketing and communications
spend a lot of time online
and consume
relevant 2017 content
from people that
are actually doing it,
not professors that
are so not practical and
so romantic of how it used to be
that I've traveled the best
universities in the world
and have literally
thrown up all over myself
while I've been prepped to talk
listening to the horse shit
that those professors
are shoving down
these kids' throats.
(audience cheers and applause)
- [Richard] Thanks, Gary.
- You're welcome, brother.
Love you.
(laughs)
- Alright, let's calm it down.
There's a fuckin' naked dude.
Half naked, very good.
Shh.
- [Woman] I'm not going to
try to imitate you,
I have an accent,
so it's kind of difficult.
- Understood.
- But you are my
role model for business
and for confidence,
I want to tell you.
- Thank you very much.
- And, um, I provide a service,
I help product-based businesses
build their business
faster, make more money.
- Okay.
- And my question is
around calls to action
for people who provide a service
- Okay
- And I'm already
really focusing
on providing a lot of value
- Yes
- in everything I do,
blog posts, video, et cetera,
and you were saying before that
you don't convince people,
like, to buy what you have,
I have, like, big packages,
I have smaller packages
so calls to action
- Yes
- might provide value.
- So calls to action for
you of the organizations
or for when people land
on those people's websites
like from UI/UX standpoint?
- For me, for example,
when I do a Facebook Live
and I provide--
- Yes.
- the biggest tip
for product pricing--
- Yes.
- And at the end
of that video,
I want to have a call to action.
- Understood.
I'm not against that
and I think we all,
you know, a lot of this is
macro- and micro-conversation.
For example, a lot of you know
that I don't ask for anything
and then every
two or three years
when a book is on sale,
I get very right-hooky
and I'm asking hardcore,
and I'm basically asking for you
to, like, not pay your mortgage
and use it to
buy the book, right?
So, what's really
been interesting
in doing that now three times
is I forgot, and even it's,
you know, it's funny,
I almost kinda
want to forget, 'cause
it's so disheartening.
I spend two years
just really giving,
and then I start selling
in a three month period,
but I forget that
somebody might have
just got into my ecosystem
and I haven't had
the chance to
provide that upfront value.
Look, this is a business.
A lot of people, and,
how many people here
are familiar with
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook?
(cheers)
Cool.
So when I wrote
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook,
a lot of people
thought that I wrote it
for the people that
didn't understand
to give, give, give
and then ask, right?
People thought that
I was pushing the jab.
Because everybody was asking.
The ironic thing was,
I wrote that book
for the people that
didn't know how to ask.
I'd so many friends that
were providing value,
and they were like, "Hit me up."
And like,
"I'm doing everything right."
I'm like, "Except you didn't
ask for any business."
So, I would say that there's
a lot of ways to do it.
I would say you should ask
for the call to action,
but I also think that
you should be strategic
about the call to action.
For example,
when you can put in your copy
a link to a landing page
that does it for you,
instead of you
yelling it over and over
at the end of the video,
you're in essence asking for it.
I would be very strategic about
what your social media
profiles are linking out to.
I'm always changing that.
Again, a lot of you know
this, I say this to you:
don't listen to what I'm saying,
pay attention to what I'm doing.
There's a reason
I'm changing the URL
in my Twitter and
especially my Instagram,
'cause the attention's there
over and over and over.
And literally,
if you want to know
what I most give a shit about,
it's the URL that's
there right now,
whether that's
a piece of content,
or whether that's the book,
or my search engine,
or whatever it may be.
A wine?
That's what I care
about at that moment.
And so I would give a
lot of thought to what
you don't have to do that
the technical infrastructure
allows to do for you.
Got it?
- [Woman]Yeah, thank you.
- Yeah, you got it.
(applause)
- [Daniel] What's
going on, Gary?
- Things are awesome, bro.
- [Daniel] That's
not my question,
but I just wanted
to know what's up.
- I know, you actually
have your question
written on your phone.
Oh, on paper.
- Yeah, I know.
- You should sell that on eBay.
It's like, rare.
(audience laughter)
- My name's
Daniel Belak and you actually
walked into a podcast
I was doing at VaynerMedia,
I can't remember
if you remember, but--
- I do.
- I just wanted to quickly
give a shout out to--
- You mean the
other day in the new--
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah--
- Yeah, in the new office.
Yeah, I remember.
- Wanted to give
a shout out to DRock
because the Friday before that,
I don't know if he told you,
I was actually kicked
out of your office,
and so I wanted to thank
you for inviting me back
and having that interview.
- Yep.
- I was wondering, at the
end of every podcast I do,
I ask this question.
- [Gary] Okay.
- What's your definition of
empowerment,
and can I come take a
selfie with you onstage?
- You can, so you
can do that, now.
- Okay.
(audience laughter)
- I think empowerment, you know,
I haven't really thought about
my definition of empowerment.
I think one is...
Be careful, don't die.
I think, I think...how are you?
Good to see you, man.
You ready?
(laughter)
- Oh, yeah, can we come on
the other side and shoot?
(laughter)
- You're a piece of work,
you're a piece of work.
- Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
- Listen, listen.
Get out of here.
- Can we do one without him?
- Yes, we can
do one without him.
- Okay, yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- You got it, brother.
I think one is empowered
when they are at complete peace
with their decision making.
It is stunning to me
how not scared I am
about anything I do, nothing.
Because I think
that when your intent,
if you are able
to push your intent
to a pretty pure place,
and let me explain
what I mean by this.
I'm not fucking some sherpa,
Mother Theresa-type character.
Here's what I think I am:
I think I believe in,
you know,
meritocracy and the game.
And if you're better than
me, I'm pumped for you.
See, I think the problem
is, so many people
want to win at
somebody else's expense,
without understanding
that there's
so many variations of winning,
and every one
of us has a totally
different definition for it.
And so, for me, this has
been so easy, this journey,
'cause my intent is pure:
I want to build the biggest
fucking building in town.
I want to win, number one.
Most money, most impact,
best, best looking,
you know, whatever, all that.
But, I want to
do it by actually doing it.
I want to build
the biggest building
by building the
biggest building.
I see way too
many people wanting
to build the biggest building
by tearing everybody
else's buildings down.
And so I feel empowered because
I feel like it comes
from a good place
and I don't question myself.
I don't ever worry about it,
I know what
I'm doing, I'm doing it
for a good reason, I'm human,
I'll make mistakes,
I'll own the shit
out of those mistakes
if I make them,
VaynerMedia, every one of
it's problems, my fault.
You want the riches that
comes along with it?
You better take the shit
that comes along with it.
And so, I think it's intent.
When you've got your intent
in the right place,
I think you're empowered.
- My man?
- [Daniel]
Thank you so much, bro.
- You got it, my man.
Good to see you.
- Hey Gary.
I just want to
thank you publicly
for fitting in on my
birthday in February 26.
I requested on Twitter
26 seconds of your time,
and your team made it happen.
It was awesome.
But I wanted to
ask you this question.
It was too cold
outside that day,
and you were on
your way to a game.
So I run a creative
studio, a creative agency,
and I know that you have,
I think it's 600 plus
person agency now, obviously.
Three or four locations.
My question.
- 705.
- 705, all right.
(audience chuckling)
You gotta keep updating
the bios there, man.
- [Gary] I get it. (laughing) Go
ahead.
- So, my question is you
never really talk about
how you would go
from two or three people,
five people, to 500, right?
It's a dramatic shift.
What would be like your key
hires, or your key strategies?
There's so many solo
entrepreneurs here,
individual entrepreneurs.
- [Gary] Yes.
- What's the gap
between one and 500?
- I think the biggest
difference between me
and a lot of my friends when
I audit what they're doing,
is too many of you that
have your own business
want shit too soon.
Too many of you
take money off the table.
I built my dads' business
from a
$3 to a $60 million business.
But, quicker, I built it from
$3 to $30 in three years.
I was 25 years old.
A lot of my friends
went to good schools,
got good jobs, made
100,000 a year got a BMW,
and I was paying
myself $47,000 a year
and living in a shit apartment.
Because I was investing
it to build a foundation.
Too many people in this
room, wanna build a business
but are taking
too big of a salary,
or taking profit interests
to buy a fucking watch.
(audience applause)
Maybe you can
go on one vacation.
Not four.
Rick.
(audience laughing)
And so, I think there's
several differences.
I think I'm dramatically
more talented than everybody
in this room in selling, so
that helps me grow faster.
I think I give a fuck
way more about people
than most people in this room,
which allows me to have
continuity of team.
And care about HR.
So for me, the way I built
my companies are HR and sales
and not taking money off
the table to buy dumb shit.
Cool.
- [Man 2] Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, Gary. My name's Michelle.
- [Gary] Hey Michelle.
- Since I've been waiting in
line you answered pretty much
every question that was
rolling through my head.
- [Gary] Awesome!
Nice meeting you. Next?
- [Michelle] No! (giggling)
- Oh sorry! Sorry.
- So I was just wondering
if I could come up there
and get a selfie with you?
- [Gary] For sure.
- 'Cause I love you so much.
- I love you so much.
(audience laughing)
Cool. Who's next?
What's up man?
- [James] Hey there.
James, again.
- Hey man.
- And I'm the host of the Dynamo
show on Rogers Television.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- That's not what
I'm gonna ask you about.
- [Gary] But it was
a tremendous plug
and let's clap it
up for the hustle.
- [James] Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you so much!
(kissing)
- Straight up, I have four
friends that have died
from drug overdoses.
I have one friend that's
died from gang violence.
I spent time in prison.
I resonate with Dan's story.
It brought me to tears.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I ran out and gave
him a hug and first up
I wanna thank
Giovanni for bringing you
and the rest of
these amazing speakers.
(audience clapping)
So my question is, I'm
looking to open up a ranch
for at risk teens.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I do everything, from
spending full days with kids
that have attempted
to commit suicide.
I work with a
gang exiting program
in the Jane and Finch region
and they need
a permanent facility.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I found a facility.
It's $2.6 million.
I could probably buy
it for $2 million.
I need to do a $1 million
raise from social media.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Your professional opinion?
What's the best and most
effective way to do that?
- Well, look.
A lot of the Kickstarter
platforms are out there, right?
You make the video, you
get the emotional play,
you get the right one or two
funders, it creates virality.
The problem is, that's a
one to three percent chance.
Right? But I still think
you should do that.
I think you can definitely
get somebody to create.
I'm sure there's three people
that'll raise there hand now
to do the video work on that
project, and away you go.
There ya go.
The dude with no
fuckin' shirt of course.
(audience laughter)
- [Man] 30 days, baby. 30 days.
- This guy.
Anyway.
- [Man] With our clothes on.
- Clothes off.
Here's what I would say.
I would say you
should do the following.
I think you should do
enormous amounts of homework
on the people
with Dan's profile.
The tens of thousands of people
that can associate to that story
and I think that you
should make a video
and I think you
should email it to them.
And I think you should
do that to 10,000 people.
And it should be specific
to them which would mean
that it will take
you the entire year.
I guarantee you'll raise
the million dollars,
versus what everybody else does.
Which is hope that
somehow it works out,
look to do it by not
spending an entire year
putting in the work.
And so I think you should
go home, map the 10,000
most likely people to
give you between $5,000
and $1 million.
Literally the ninth
person you ask
that is a high
net worth individual
that connects with your story
may give you
the million in one shot.
But I think you've gotta do
the scaling the un-scalable.
Go read the profiles.
Go look at the 100,000 richest
people in Canada or the world
Google search it
out all the way through.
Figure out the
1,500 people that most map.
Send them a very direct
contextual to them.
The amount of people that
spam me without any context,
no romance, they just
want shit from me, right?
It happens to all those
kinds of people everyday.
So you've gotta give
them something different.
You need to be thoughtful
about the headline
that you email with.
Don't do cliche shit.
I get 900 emails
a week that say,
"I'm gonna help
you buy the Jets."
That's an automatic delete.
So you need to
be clever and smart.
And that's how you'll raise it
and you'll raise it within one
year if you do it that way.
Money in the bank.
(audience clapping)
- [James] Thank you.
- You got it.
- [James] On behalf of the
boys, you've been a help.
- You got it, man.
And bro? And bro?
Yo.
And I'm in for 50K.
(audience cheering)
- [James] Fuckin' A! (yells)
(laughing)
(audience applauding)
- [Gary] Let's move it.
Let's move it.
- Hey Gary, my name's Jamaal.
- [Gary] No wonder
Oprah does that shit.
(audience laughing)
That felt good.
- My name's Jamal.
- [Gary] Jamal.
- My question is you talk a
lot about how giving people
their time back is really
powerful and important.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I read a article you wrote
about how virtual reality's
gonna be the next big thing
in the next maybe five to
seven years such as like
the Iphone or the Internet.
And so what my question is,
which industry do you
think is gonna utilize
virtual reality the most
in terms of saving time
and what are you looking
for as an investor
in a virtual reality business?
- So I'm not sure.
You know just like I believe
that the Internet was gonna
be the platform that we
lived our lives I definitely
believe that something
like VR is where
we're gonna live our lives.
I think in that article I
talked about five to seven years
before we saw
the beginning stages,
and the article was more
predicated on it's coming,
but way too many people
think it's coming now.
There's a lot of people
investing in VR and think in 24
months we're all gonna be
walking around with headsets.
It's not happening.
We're just so far away from
human behavior on that level,
but over 10, 15, 20 years if
we're in contact lenses I mean
things change very
quickly you know,
online dating 10 years ago was
the most taboo weird shit ever,
no 98% of this room is
swiping the right, right?
(audience laughs)
So I would sit
left you're pretty,
you're tough, fuck.
(audience laughs)
So I would say that I don't
know because when I knew
the Internet was gonna be a
big deal I didn't know it was
gonna be limo services,
hotels and bookstores that were
gonna be addressed first.
I don't know but I know that
I'll be looking out for it.
I think the thing to
think about is not so much
which companies to invest in,
but where are the opportunities,
like what do we do now that
requires us to leave our
apartment that VR
may be better than
our cell or the internet,
whether that's shopping 'cause
we can see the product on us,
I don't know what it is,
but I promise you this.
For the people in here
that haven't started
thinking about the VR process,
your parents and
grandparents thought
the Internet was a fad.
They thought it would be the
weirdest thing ever that you
met somebody on a computer and
decided to marry them, right?
They would think it's
insane that you buy a tomato
through a computer device
if I told you that in 1985.
So there's a lot of change,
the answer is I don't know
how to answer that question
other than I will tell you this.
You're young as fuck right?
If you believe in this you
should get very educated,
go to every meetup,
read every article,
don't jump to conclusions,
don't be impatient like
all your contemporaries.
Learn, make relationships,
if you want to make money in VR,
you can make it
how old are you, 22?
- [Jamaal] 19.
- 19?
(audience laughs)
Dude you weren't alive when
I launched WineLibrary.com.
(audience laughs)
And I need you
to understand that.
You have so much time.
If you were just patient for
the next 19 years of your life
and built the foundation
to make the money on VR,
you would still be two years
younger than me right now.
So I promise you,
don't try to figure out
something that
hasn't been figured out.
React to what it is figured
out and use the leverage you
created in this next seven
years to be able to be in a
position to react
in a fruitful manner.
(audience applause)
What's up my man?
- Gary.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Thanks for everything,
thanks for your time.
My question is what is your
biggest challenge right now,
and how can I or
we help you overcome it?
- That's very sweet.
(audience laughs)
I first and foremost another
flaw of mine is I have no
interest in anybody
helping me do anything.
It's a very immigrant kind of,
like it's the most,
like I almost punched you in
the face for that question.
(audience laughs)
Like it's so weird.
It's so weird that
that's visceral to me.
I think my biggest challenge is,
(laughs)
It's weird, right?
So I think my
biggest challenge is
I'm like a fat
kid with cake, right?
Like I have big eyes.
I think I can do
everything, right?
I have so much energy,
I have so many ideas and wants,
and I'm so attracted to
doing 947,000 things at once.
I've proven to
myself multiple times that
that's how I lose
on a micro level.
I don't know man,
as you can tell,
I'm sure I have tons of
challenges
I think the punchline is
I'm just not sure what they are.
It's way deeper than you think.
Unwind that one.
I know I have a lot of them,
I just don't think it's smart
to spend so much time on them.
Which then makes me feel
like I don't have any.
(audience laughs)
I think so,
like thank you so much for
the question but I don't know,
we all have challenges like,
I don't know like
my ankle hurts.
(audience laughs)
But do you know what I mean?
Like I think my friends,
I think dwelling is a disease.
I think complaining
is a disease.
I can't even allow myself
with the gratitude that is
running through my body
articulate to an audience
that's actually spending their
time paying attention to me
that I have some challenge.
Whatever challenge I have,
I made that fuckin' bed,
and I'm gonna sleep in it.
- [Jamaal] Okay, how
about the business side?
- I'm cruising.
That's the easiest
part of all time.
The business side
is the only thing that,
that to me is fuckin' for,
do you know what a forgone
fucking conclusion is?
(audience laughter)
Yeah that's fine.
- [Man 3] Thank you.
(audience laughter)
Cool, thank you.
(audience applause)
- Hey man.
- Hey Gary my name's Seyon.
- [Gary] Seyon.
- Yes, it's no yes
spelled backwards,
that's how you remember it.
It's a random brown name
you're not gonna remember it.
- [Gary] Respect.
- What I love most about you is
besides the motivation hoorah,
you have such actual advice.
It's like one,
and this feeds into my question.
About a month ago a
switch flicked in my head,
I was like wow.
I gotta be helping
people on a regular basis
to feel that leverage,
and that comes from
you just continuously
- Pounding.
Pounding 51/49, 51/49.
Here's my question.
I graduated I worked on startup,
I'm a developer.
- [Gary] Okay.
- 22 years old.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I don't know
which muscle to flex.
Should I be in my room
working on a product
and coding all day all night?
Should I be spending
some of that time
cultivating maintaining
relationships?
For a technical
person in technology,
what would your advice be?
- Both.
- [Seyon] Okay.
Both, thank you.
(audience laughs)
- Yo.
Thank you brother,
real pleasure.
Both, like cut out
the dumb shit,
you know what I mean?
Like PokÊmon GO,
what the fuck?
(audience laughs)
Hey.
- Hi, my name's Julie Boye and
I actually dream of a world
where everyone wakes up
and simply says thank you,
- [Gary] Yes, we got a lot of
fuckin' work to do Jules.
- Yeah, that's okay.
(audience laughs)
That's why I'm working
with the guys who are doing
the Gratitude App 'cause
I think that's amazing,
so I have a blog,
I have a book.
My question for you is if you
were to start a blog today
in this environment,
how would you disseminate
that information,
like what would be the best
way for you to get that blog
so that people are reading it?
What tools would you use?
- [Gary] It's the same thing,
remember when I said earlier
in the speech that like
basically if you saw my
speech from 10 years ago,
it would be the same thing,
it would just be
different things.
10 years ago I would say okay,
so you've gotta
make it on Blogger,
you know I like Blogger,
there's a community there,
and then what you do
is you get an RSS feed
and really push
to that call to action,
and I would hit up other
bloggers to guest blog
because that will
bring you awareness,
da da da.
Today that answer is the same
it's just slightly different.
Ironically it's the
same guy that built it.
Medium to me is probably
the place where I would blog
because it's the one place
where you can get virality
even if you don't
have an audience.
Then you need to produce
content that is a gateway drug
to your articles on all
your social channels.
So you need to build
up Twitter and Facebook
and Pinterest and
all those platforms
so they become
gateways to your blog.
Then you have to e-mail people
that are writing content in
your sphere and ask
them to guest blog,
so that your provide them value
by giving them good content
and they provide you
value by them giving
you exposure to their audience.
Then you reach out to Forbes
and The Observer and all these
different media sites and
say this is what you do,
and would they like any
free articles, exposure.
So many people are
visceral to spec work.
When you have no leverage,
spec work is your
best friend, right?
So you need to provide
value in your content,
that's what you have right?
And what you need is attention.
So you need to go to
anybody that has attention
and figure out what's the
best thing that they could do.
Somebody got mad
at me the other day
for asking for some spec work.
Can anybody give
me some aerial footage
in Chicago for our blog?
And he's like,
"Why don't you fuckin' pay
for it you can afford it?"
I go I can,
or I can do something for
somebody that
I do my whole life.
I still do events just for
the branding and the exposure.
When I had a big business and
I wanted to get into tech,
I e-mailed
Leo Laporte and
Jaiku the app that was
competing with Twitter.
They had a meetup
in San Francisco,
and I said can I come and
pour wine at your event?
So I made it,
yet I had nothing but
loads of humility knowing
I didn't mean shit in tech
and I was gonna go fly,
and I fuckin' was the help
to make relationships.
Way too many people
are fucking fancy
and think they're special.
What you need to
do is you need to
put in the work to get exposure.
- [Julie] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
- Can I extend it a
little bit or are we so,
like, I'm rolling.
Gotta cut it?
- No, we got V.I.P. after it.
- We got V.I., can I go
like 10 minutes?
Cool, alright, thank you.
- [Kimberly] Hi Gary,
my name is Kimberly.
- [Gary] Hey Kimberly.
- I am in the wellness field,
I heal people,
- Great.
And I heard you
have a sore ankle
P.S. I happened to have brought
my hands with me.
- I was joking about the ankle
but if you want to rub my ankle,
I'm super weirdly into it.
- I'm a registered
massage therapist and
I brought my hands with me.
(laughing)
- Okay, go ahead.
- So, I own a
massage therapy clinic
way back in New Brunswick,
I'm with my son, Brandon,
he traveled from there.
- Where's Brandon?
- Brandon's right here,
he introduced me to you
a year ago.
- Hey Brandon.
- I've absorbed tons
of your content and--
- Hold on, hold on, hold on.
- Listen.
- Hold on, hold on.
That's your son?
- That's Brandon, that's my son.
- You look fuckin' great.
(audience laughing)
Right?
(audience applauding)
- I might say too Gary, you
look fantastic in person,
you look awesome.
- Thank you.
Okay, keep going.
- My question is,
I've always
wanted to take what I do
in the wellness field of
massage therapy and bring it
into the workplace where people
spend most of their time.
- [Gary] I think that's smart.
- I find, in my experience
it's very difficult
for people to find time to come
to us around their work.
- Totally,
I think it's super smart.
Embedded within organization,
I'm very into this B2B
model so keep going.
- So, what I want to be able
to do is to put
our business,
what we do into the workplace.
- [Gary] Super smart, next.
- How, I want to know,
and I feel like,
- You email,
you email TD Bank Corporate.
- All of them?
- All of them until--
- So where do I start and I
- Your computer.
- want this to be everywhere.
(audience laughing)
- I'm not joking right now,
Brandon.
- Yup.
- I need you to push
this through as well.
Email every single business
in Canada that can afford it,
tell them what you do, and wait
for the people that say yes
to say yes and then go do it.
- And, but do
I do that, hire people,
if I'm in one province
and I want this to be,
eventually go, you know--
- Before you franchise and
become fuckin' Tim Hortons.
- [Kimberly] I won't franchise!
- Okay, but here's what you do,
- Tim Hortons?
- Ready?
Do a second one.
- Right.
- Well, hold on, do a first one.
The amount of entrepreneurs
that are worried about shit
that's gonna
happen in 2024, you don't,
how many clients, how
many companies right now
have this embedded in
their company from you?
The answer's zero.
- Zero.
- Let's worry about--
- And this is the first time
I've actually said it out loud.
- I'm fired up about that.
(audience cheering)
Here's what I would say,
one of the things
that has really worked for
me is you need to understand
where it's going long term,
but you need to address
what's in front of you.
Let's get the first client,
before we worry about the
Calgary and Edmonton Market.
- [Kimberly] Absolutely.
(audience chuckles)
- Now, go.
- [Kimberly] Oh, one last thing,
I have--
- Go ahead Brandon.
- [Kimberly] Really quick
question, oh sorry Brandon
go ahead.
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- Such a sweet family.
- I want to know if,
Gary, is there anybody in your
office actually named Rick,
because I feel bad for
Rick, does he need therapy?
- Yes.
(audience laughs)
There's nobody in
my office named Rick.
For a lot of you that
don't know me,
I just use this imaginal
character named Rick,
as the guy that
just does everything
against everything I believe in.
Like, you know, "But I
believe in Yellow Pages."
Fuck you Rick, you know.
(audience laughing)
"She should really worry
about expansion globally."
You're wrong Rick, you
know, that kind of shit.
Just the anti-me,
I fuckin' hate Rick.
Yes, Brandon?
- [Brandon] We drove 14
hours here to see you,
can we get a selfie?
- Yes, awesome, let's move it.
(audience applause)
- Hey Gary, I'm 19 years
old from New Jersey.
- [Gary] I love that, where?
- New Brunswick,
I'm at Rutgers right now.
- [Gary] Wow, super close
to Edison, I love it.
- Yeah, what would you have
told your 19-year old self
if he was in
the room right now--
- To hook up with more chicks.
(audience laughing)
- [Brandon] You're a
game-changer, man.
- [Gary] Thank you bro.
- And if you're looking
for employee number 706,
I missed an internship
fair to be here right now,
so, I'm open.
- Ready, hold on one second.
(audience laughs)
Oh.
Got it.
- Awesome.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you man.
- Thank you bro.
(audience laughing)
Did you just ask for an
internship?
- Yeah.
- You got it.
- Alright, hey.
(audience applauding)
- We're just givin'
away shit tonight.
- Alright, Gary Vee.
- By the way, I'm dead
serious, are you gonna do it
in May when you're
done or you ready now?
- [Audience] Right now!
- Just email me,
gary@vaynermedia, cool.
- Alright Gary, my name is Twon,
I represent a bunch of
conscience business dads.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- And basically it's about
leadership, you know.
And do you believe
first of all that great,
awesome fatherhood is linked
to awesome leadership?
- [Gary] A hundred percent.
- And what's your
one is more than, is better
than zero that you do everyday
to make yourself
a better father?
- That's a great question, so,
the one is greater than zero,
the way you asked the question
is interesting because
the punchline of that,
I want to make sure we're
on the same wavelength
is I'm just stunned how many,
it's actually back to that
last great question of,
I just think people are fancy.
Like people want to do all
this stuff and they aren't
willing to put in the work
for a little gain today,
and they end up doing nothing
because they just don't do it.
And so like anything is greater,
back to that lovely lady and
Brandon that just came up.
Like if they email 400
people and one says yes,
that's better than zero clients.
Like you gotta put in a lot
of work to get a very little
in the beginning because
you have no leverage
and then you build on it.
As far as the father
thing, it's interesting.
I'm in a very funny spot
with my kids because my kids,
so I really am very
disrespectful of
my children, right.
So, meaning I think
they're gonna be soft,
because they're rich, right,
and so a lot of what I'm
thinking about right now
and a lot of what I do with
my children is I'm trying
to honor being parented
the way that I was.
Meaning, I think that
I was perfectly parented,
like my parents
fucking crushed it.
And so, what my parents did
was, I was an immigrant right.
How many people were immigrants
or children of immigrants?
So, education right,
pushed so hard, so clichÊ,
and my parents saw, or my
mom saw that I wasn't that,
I was something else and
she allowed me to do that,
and I've had such
happiness because of that.
And if she boxed me in,
I wouldn't have.
So the thing that I'm
allowing my children to do is,
I watch my children everyday
and I overexaggerate the things
that I think they naturally
love and are great at.
I want to give them
permission, if my daughter,
so many of my entrepreneur
friends are like,
you want your kids to be
entrepreneurs?
I'm like, not necessarily,
I want my kids to love
whatever they do the way
I love being an entrepreneur.
And if that means my
daughter wants to be
the greatest painter
using tomatoes,
(audience laughs)
fine.
And so, the thing that I'm
trying to do every single day
is pay attention to
who they actually are,
so that I can then
reverse engineer them,
versus what the majority
of my friends are doing,
which is mold them into
what they want them to be.
- [Man 3] Fantastic,
can I have a hug?
- Yes.
(audience applause)
- [Colin] Gary, what's up?
- Things are phenomenal.
- Awesome.
My name is Colin.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- My name is Colin.
- [Gary] Colin, real pleasure.
- I have a tactical
question actually,
- [Gary] Great, let's do it.
- I love the #AskGaryVee Show.
I love how you give such
in-depth answers
and I think that's a skill
everybody could have if you're
in the boardroom,
job interview, press conference.
What are the components
of a kick-ass answer?
- Wow, that's a great questions
So, you're asking me,
what make the components
of a great answer?
- [Colin] Yes.
- Knowing the answer.
(audience laughing)
I'm being dead fuckin' serious.
One of the things that
I love about switching
to a lot of Q&amp;A, it
hasn't happened here yet,
and it doesn't happen a lot
because people
usually don't go there with me.
But somebody asked something
about a Stephen Hawking's thing
at that event that we were at.
Nonetheless, my favorite thing
to do in this environment
is to just answer the question,
I don't know,
and literally move on.
And it's really interesting
because the crowd loves it
because it just made
every other answer real
and I'm so comfortable
in my place now
of saying I don't know.
If somebody went super
technically deep
around the functionality
of something on GitHub
that I wouldn't know the answer
to, I would know something
may be dangerous but
I don't know in detail.
I think the reason the
#AskGaryVee show works well is,
I either know it
very detailed, the dirt,
or I really understand it in
the clouds, theoretically,
and I'm able to
answer those questions.
I don't know the questions
before we do the show
and you see how it goes.
So, I think the component
is knowing the answer
and I think that's
why so many of us,
especially the
youngsters in this room,
and I surely did it, we grossly
underestimate experience.
Like it blows my mind how
much better I am today
than the 25-year-old
version of me,
even though I thought that
guy was the most unstoppable
force of business
nature ever created.
I just do, and so I think
that knowing the answer.
That's why, the show's working
because they're good answers
and my audience like
that, my buddy who said
you keep pounding into me,
the 19-year old, like 51/49,
like I am gonna suffocate
the seven or eight principles
that I believe in on you for
as long as you pay attention
to me and I will never change.
I'm gonna bore the
living shit out of you
because there's only so many
things that actually work.
They're just not that
attractive, especially right now
when everybody
thinks it's so easy.
- [Colin] Thanks man.
- Thanks man.
(audience applause)
- One more, one more?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- One more, one more
alright, perfect perfect.
- One on each side?
(audience laughing)
- Beauty okay, alright Gary.
- I'm here.
- I wanna be respectful
because I know Giovanni's
trying to wrap it up,
so let me keep it quick.
I've been following
you for a long time
and if there's one thing
that I know about you is that
you're a fuckin'
competitor and I want--
- [Gary] Yes.
- to challenge you right now.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So,
there's a game that me
and my friends play,
it's called Odds, it takes
10 seconds for me to explain,
five seconds for us to
play, but if I win I want
a one-on-on meeting
with you for an hour,
I'll fly down to
New York just to do it.
- [Gary] So, let me
get this straight.
You and your cockamanian
friends made up a fuckin' game.
- [Man 4] Absolutely.
(audience laughs)
- That you understand
every variable within--
- Dude, it's the easiest
game, it's a guessing game.
- Okay.
- You want to play?
- Who gets to be the judge
and the jury of the answer?
- Pardon me?
- [Gary] Who's the judge and
the jury of the answer?
- Beauty, beauty,
we have some judges
but you're not
gonna need judges--
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- Okay cool,
so how it works is you and I
on the count of three, I'm
gonna go three, two, one,
and you and I are
gonna say a number
between one and 10, alright.
- Okay.
- If I get your number
than you and I sit down
for a 60-minute meeting in
New York on your schedule.
- [Gary] Done.
- Are you into it?
- So, you're gonna
go one, two, three,
and I'm gonna say a number?
- I'm gonna three, two, one,
and then we're gonna get to 10.
- Hold on, you're gonna
go three, two, one,
- And then you're gonna say
a number between one and 10,
that's it.
- 'Kay.
- Everybody got it?
- Yeah.
- Alright, three, two, one,
[Man 4] seven.
- [Gary] Nine.
- [Man 4] Fuck.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheering)
- [Woman 2]Hey Gary.
- I fuckin' won!
- Yeah!
(audience applauding)
- Everyone, Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Man 5] Gary,
you're my ghost mentor!
(audience cheering)
- [Woman] This sucks,
I had a question.
Oh.